Welcome to "The Next Level."
Right now, I'm here with my
guy, all the way from Detroit
and the heart of the city.
I'm talking about Jeff
Horste, ladies and gentlemen.
Give him some love.
Jeff Horste.
Let's talk about Detroit, man.
You know, you play shows
with black audiences.
What adjustments do you feel
like you have to make, if any?
Really, I think it
was just because--
it wasn't the black
audiences as much
as just some of the
rooms in Detroit
were just harder
rooms to perform in.
I love that answer.
So I just put a
funnier joke up top.
There you go.
And then I did
my set as normal.
It wasn't really--
it wasn't a change.
Those are the jokes
that I enjoy telling.
I love that answer.
And finally, I had an audience
that understood them more.
Because it shouldn't matter.
It shouldn't matter.
Funny is funny.
Well, you know what,
right now I want
to learn some stuff about
you by looking at a photo.
OK.
Here's Jeff's senior
high school picture.
Jeff, do me a favor, man.
Explain what was
going on here, please.
You see, I grew facial
hair at a very young age.
He looks older than you now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You look like a detective.
Doesn't he look like
an undercover cop?
You just look like
you're wearing a wire.
What was one of the strangest
experiences that you had?
I've had a few.
I've performed at
nudist colonies.
I'm sorry.
What?
I got booked to perform
at a nudist colony.
Back up.
Stop for a second.
First of all, who's
booking this gig?
Not that I want to go,
but if there's a promoter,
who do I get in touch
with about the nudist gig?
I don't know if they want
to be mentioned on camera.
There's naked
people in the crowd?
Yeah, Yeah.
So literally,
literally, you're doing
stand-up and there's naked
people, just naked people.
There's no way.
And they're a little
uptight about it.
You'd think they would--
they weren't as relaxed
of a comedy room
as you would imagine.
That is the up there.
That's up there with
one of the strangest
that I've ever heard, man.
I'm actually sorry that
you had to go through that.
I am 100% apologizing
on their behalf.
That shouldn't have
happened to you.
You're a good kid, man.
00:02:09,830 --> 00:00:00,000
Now, this guy, this guy, it
should have happened to him.